how do we think about self-driving cars
the technology is essentially here and
we now have to take a technology in
which machines can make a bunch of quick
decisions often times quicker than we
can that could drastically reduce
traffic fatalities could drastically
improve the efficiency of our
transportation grid helped solve things
like carbon emissions that are caused
causing the warming of the planet but
Joey made a very elegant and simple
point which is what are the values that
we're going to embed in the cars if in
fact we're going to get all the benefits
of self-driving cars and how do we make
the public comfortable with it now some
of its just right now the overriding
concern of the public is safety
the notion of essentially taking your
hands off the wheel
but as Joey pointed out there going to
be a bunch of choices that you have to
make you know a classic problem being if
the cars are driving and you can swerve
to avoid a pedestrian who maybe wasn't
paying attention it's not your fault but
if you swerve you're going to go into a
wall and might kill yourself and how do
you make the calculations about odds and
airbags and speed and all that that you
can have that machine make that decision
but that's a moral decision not just a
pure utilitarian decision and who's
setting up those rules do we have broad
consensus around what those rules are
that's going to be important we're going
to have the same set of questions when
it comes to medicine we have invested
heavily in thinking about precision
medicine or individualized medicine
thinking about how the combination of
the human genome and
you know computer data and a large
enough sample size can potentially
arrive at a whole host of cures
Parkinson's Alzheimer's cancer there are
a whole bunch of interesting choices
that we're going to have to make as we
perceiving this because the better we
get at it the more predictive we are
about certain genetic variations having
an impact how we think about insurance
how we think about medical pricing who
gets what when how is that something
that we're going to hand out over to an
algorithm and if so who's writing it so
so these are going to be unavoidable
questions and I think that Joe is
exactly right making sure that the broad
public that's not necessarily going to
be following every single iteration of
this debate still feels as if their
voice is heard they're represented that
the people in the room are mindful of a
range of equities that's going to be
really important and what is the role of
government in that context as we start
to get an idiot' ethical questions well
my instinct is initially the role is a
convener the way I've been thinking
about the regulatory structure as AI
emerges is that early in a technology a
thousand flowers should bloom and the
government should have a relatively
light touch investing heavily in
research making sure that there's a
conversation between basic research and
applied research and companies that are
trying to figure out how to apply it you
know a good example of where this has
worked pretty well I think is in
predicting the weather got big data
really complex systems government bases
that hey we got all this data and
suddenly a whole bunch of folks are
around and working with the National
Weather Center and developing new apps
and we've actually been able to predict
an oncoming tornado three four times
faster than it used to be would that
saves lives that's a that's a good
example of where the government isn't
doing all the work initially but his
inviting others to participate as
technologies emerge and mature then
figuring out how they get incorporated
into existing regulatory structures
becomes a tougher problem and the
government needs to be involved a little
bit more not always to force the new
technology into the square peg that
exists but maybe to change the peg and
one of the things that we're trying to
do for example is to get the Federal
Drug Administration the FDA to redesign
how it's thinking about genetic medicine
when a lot of its rules regulations were
designed for a time when you know it was
worrying about a heart stent that is a
very different problem so basic research
from government convening to make sure
the conversations are happening ensuring
transparency but as things mature making
sure that there is a transition and a
seamless way to get the technology to
rethink regulations and as Joey pointed
out making sure that the regulations
themselves reflect a broad base set of
values because otherwise if it's not
transparent you know we may find that
it's disadvantaging certain people
certain groups or that the public is
just suspicious of it
I could say one thing about that so
there's cut ice of two things so one is
when we did the this car trolley problem
thing we found that most people liked
the idea that the driver or the
passenger could be sacrificed to save
many people but they would never buy
that car that was that that was a short
version of the result the other related
thing which is I don't know if you've
heard the neurodiversity movement but
this is a this if we solve autism let's
say and Temple Grandin talks about this
a lot she says that Mozart and Einstein
and Tesla would all be considered
autistic if they were here today I don't
know that's true but something might be
on the spectrum so if we were able to
eliminate autism and make everyone
neural normal normal I bet a whole swath
of MIT kids would not be the way they
are and you know you probably wouldn't
want any same as your kid this is
somebody who was in Cambridge at the
Harvard Law School be here III didn't
want to echo that stereotype about it in
someone's therapy but some other
brilliant kids are kind of on the
spectrum and I think one of the things
that's really important whether we're
talking about autism or just diversity
broadly one of the problems I think is
that allowing the market and each
individual to decide ok I just want a
normal kid and I want a car that's going
to protect me is not going to lead to a
maximum for the societal benefit and I
think that whether it's government or
something we can't just have this market
driven and I think a lot of these
decisions are going to be like that I
think there's a great point and it
actually goes to the larger issue that
we wrestle with all the time around AI
and and science fiction taps into this
all the time part of what makes us human
are the kinks they're the mutations
they're the outliers they're the flaws
that create art or the new invention
right we we have to assume that if a
system is perfect then it's static
and part of what makes us who we are
part of what makes us alive is that is
dynamic and we're surprised one of the
challenges that we'll have over time is
to think about where are those areas
where it's entirely appropriate for us
just to have things work exactly the way
they're supposed to without surprises
now so airline flight might be a good
example where you know I'm not that
interested in having surprises if I have
a smooth flight every time I'm fine be
just fine right